humans have finally realized their
mistakes and put efforts to make earth
more green they have achieved Perfection
and almost all diseases have disappeared
but one young man gets bored of his
peaceful life and decides to go on a
dangerous space mission after years of
hard work and dedication humans have
finally solved all the climate problems
and developed Technologies to cope with
any disease crops are harvested in
Perfection so there's enough food for
all living beings governments have made
peace so no one has to worry about
crimes or terrorism Earth has become an
ideal place to live but the new
generation find it boring they also want
to have problems to solve so a space
organization has started a program in
which youngsters are sent to explore
other planets this is a new hobby and
one of the people who loves it is a
young boy named Maxim he is quite a
reckless guy and chooses space
exploration just for fun while he is in
the spaceship he receives a call from
his caring Grandma who wants to know
when he is going to come back home she
has no idea that Maxim is gliding in
space he has spent spent several years
in study and when the final exams are
right around Maxim is wasting his time
the grandma advises him to return as
soon as possible and must call his dad
as he is also worried about Maxim's
studies Maxim understands his family's
concern and dials his dad's number
before he can reach him the call drops
because a bunch of meteors have hit the
spaceship Maxim panics and tries his
best to handle the ship but he fails
miserably the spaceship completely shuts
down and crashes on a weird planet as he
gains back his senses maxium grabs the
necessary things and steps out of his
spaceship he gets delighted to know that
the planet has a stable atmosphere and
oxygen to breathe even the gravity is
almost the same as Earth as the
spaceship is completely destroyed moxim
must find another way to travel back
home he starts exploring and finds
several plants that look familiar
suddenly Maxim catches someone staring
at him from far it seems like a creepy
Beast that wants to eat Maxim luckily a
man reaches there and scares away the
Beast Maxim gets excited to find another
human and tries to be friendly but the
man belongs to the military who orders
Maxim to throw away all his weapons
afterward he is taken to the military
headquarters Maxim meets several other
soldiers and also their leader who
doesn't find Maxim trustworthy he
decides to do a proper investigation and
sends him to the capital city a soldier
named gy gal is given the task to
accompany moxim They Ride an Old
Carriage and Maxim assumes that this
planet hasn't developed as much as the
Earth he Peaks out with curiosity and
notices huge towers with heavy security
he wants to know more about them guy gal
believes that Maxim is dumb guy so he
takes out a diary to explain the Tower
with a diagram the towers are built to
defend the area from enemies while he is
explaining it the tower blasts all of a
sudden the enemies have attacked
everyone runs to save their lives Maxim
can escape too but he gets worried for
gay who is a weird attack because of a
mysterious sound the people nearby call
this a medical condition called
degeneration surprisingly guy recovers
by himself after a while and continues
the journey they reach the capital which
is unexpectedly a modern town with
high-tech cars and Sky touching
buildings Maxim is taken to a weird
Doctor Who runs several unnecessary
tests on the innocent guy the news of
Maxim's arrival spreads around and Nomad
A high- ranked government officer wants
to meet Maxim a man named Funk arrives
to take Maxim to his master Nomad they
are traveling in a car but the traffic
gets in their way suddenly degeneration
happens again and it affects Funk he
totally loses himself so a group of
Agents Rush there to help him while the
public keeps calling Funk a degenerate
which seems like a notorious condition
Maxim is fed up with being carried
around so he takes this chance to escape
once Funk gets better he informs his
master about The Disappearance of Maxim
but Nomad is really disappointed he
gives just 2 days to bring Maxim
otherwise Funk has to deal with
unfavorable circumstan ances after
announcing his decision Nomad proceeds
to attend a secret meeting with a
mysterious team called the unknown
fathers they seem to be really strict
and ask each member to explain their
current activities Nomad succeeds in
satisfying the fathers but the health
officer gets accused of revealing a big
secret his mistake can't be forgiven so
the unknown fathers kill the officer on
the spot this is what they do if anyone
tries to rebel against them meanwhile
Maxim is wandering around in local
markets and realiz izes that despite the
modern structure the public in the
capital is living a really hard life
they barely have enough food to eat and
must do tough jobs to take care of their
families the unknown fathers and
government officers keep all the
luxuries just for themselves moxim also
spots a few restaurants but what catches
his eye is the gorgeous woman working
there her name is Rada and she seems
like a hardworking young lady
unfortunately she has to deal to
disrespectful customers who try to abuse
her moxim stands up against the abuser
and gives him a warning when the abuser
doesn't listen moxim knocks him down and
he impresses Rada with his unmatchable
strength R gets comfortable with her and
sits down to talk Maxim is surprised to
hear that she is actually gal's sister
after knowing that Maxim has come from a
different planet R invites him to her
place guy also returns home but he
didn't expect to see Maxim there but he
still remembers that Maxim helped him
when the degeneration hit in exchange
for that favor guy let him stay in his
house for a few days Nomad is still
after Maxim but Funk tells him that
Maxim must have died otherwise he would
have been caught by the police already
as he has no identity card little do
they know Maxim is peacefully living at
guy's place usually after dinner the
siblings like watching television their
favorite program is the video collection
of mental patients Maxim feels
uncomfortable to watch and prefers to
read books instead he misses Earth and
can't sleep peacefully he wakes up in
the middle of night and wanders on the
roof R spots him and gives him company
the people of this planet have no
knowledge of space exploration so they
don't believe that Maxim is from another
planet he wants at least Rada to believe
him so he explains to her that their
planet is just a surface from which they
can fly off to other places moxim wants
to return home and wonders if his family
is still waiting for him or not they may
have already accepted his death Rada
Comforts him and advises him not to give
up she shares her own life story to
motivate moxim her father used to serve
as a doctor in a virus outbreak he was
was such a selfless man who worked hard
to treat his patients but the government
didn't care to stop the virus they
dropped bombs on the whole contaminated
area along with the patients and doctors
Rada also felt like she would not be
able to continue living but she did and
now she has met a wonderful man like
Maxim actually she wants Maxim to
understand that it's never too late to
take a new start Maxim agrees and
decides to learn more about this planet
from the next day Guy starts teaching
Maxim more about the current
circumstances and the challenges the
public deal with every day being a
soldier guy served in several places
including the South borders where the
mutated humans live they are just like
deadly beasts and currently no one knows
how these humans turned like that the
town is full of secrets and the public
don't dare to look for the truth they
are ruled by the cruel unknown fathers
who claim to keep the town protected by
building Towers but there's a small
group of people who stand against the
fathers they usually stay hidden and
only come forward to destroy the tower
they are commonly referred to as the
degenerates guy was really angry at the
government so he joined the military to
take matters into his own hands he
wanted to be strong enough to protect
his family and friends Guy believes that
Maxim will also be suitable for this job
though he has no documents but as guy
insists his leader selects Maxim but he
has to clear all the training to
officially become a part of the military
after advancing so much in technology
the humans have modified their natural
strength as well their senses have
gotten really strong that's why moxim
has super strength and so much talent he
passes all the training sessions and
impresses all of the officers however
guy is worried about Maxim becoming a
lab rat so he advises his friend not to
show off his abilities too much a few
days pass and Maxim has already learned
so much about the weird planet now he
remembers all the history on his
fingertips there used to be a big nation
who peacefully lived on this planet but
things suddenly took the wrong turn the
nation was divided into two lands who
developed deep hatred towards each other
this information overwhelms maxium and
he needs a little break he goes for a
walk with Rada and she takes him to her
favorite place the Romantic feelings
between them grow stronger and seal
their relationship with a sweet kiss
Maxim has chosen to forget about Earth
and start a new life here a few days
later the Army attacked a building to
capture the degenerates living there
Maxim assumed that the degenerates must
be some dangerous creatures who fight
humans but they turn out to be innocent
human beings with families and friends
the soldiers shoot some of the
degenerate while the remaining ones are
tortured to accept their defeat Maxim is
quietly observing this all and he has
realized that the military is not a fair
organization Maxim wants to leave as
soon as possible the leader notices
Maxim's suspicious behavior and decides
to test him he is taken to the forest
and ordered to kill two innocent
captives Maxim lets the captives escape
and he also gives up his job the leader
gets enraged and shoots Maxim several
times meanwhile the unknown fathers are
looking forward to their own benefit as
the two nations are already fighting the
fathers plan to take over the weaker
Nation they also keep killjoy the
degenerates so there's no opposition
from there however they have a new enemy
now Maxim has a miraculously strong body
and he has survived all the bullet shots
he is rescued by a bunch of degenerates
who explain their actions the poor Gang
has no intention of harming others they
just want to destroy the towers because
the radiations emitting from them cause
a sever pain and degenerates some of the
government officers are also degenerates
but they have given up against the
unknown fathers a degeneration occurs
again and the poor gang suffers in pain
Maxim has healing power which he uses to
decrease the pain and degenerates the
Gang gets fond of him and include him in
their mission they sneak into the town
to destroy the towers and Maxim helps
them fully they succeed in damaging a
tower but two of the gang members
sacrifice their lives after the
unfortunate incident Maxim decides to
get more help and meets guy and Rada he
tells them the whole truth but Guy
believes it's not possible to destroy
all the towers as they are just too many
if Maxim really wants to start a better
life he should just run away to a
distant land with Rada before moxim can
decide the police arrive at the door
moxim wants to run away but the police
aim at Rada to make moxim give up the
poor guy lets himself get arrested but
he keeps spreading the reality of
degenerates even in the prison Nomad
wants to research Maxim but the fathers
believe he is too dangerous so they
order to kill him they do it in a
special way instead of Killing Them
normally Max Ma and two other prisoners
are thrown in the middle of a forest
full of beasts and weapons Maxim makes a
team with the other prisoners and
destroys all the weapons a beast attacks
them too but Maxim uses his super
strength to save his fellows seeing his
kindness one of the prisoners reveals
another harsh truth the unknown fathers
are brainwashing people the towers emit
special radiation which gets inside
people's nervous systems this causes the
people to believe anything the fathers
say only the degenerates don't get
affected and the unknown fathers want to
kill them to keep their dirty secret
hidden suddenly a few military tanks
pass by maxium takes one of the tanks
and heads towards a new Mission he wants
to help the public but it's not going to
be easy on his way Maxim also finds guy
he gets really excited and pulls his
friend inside they will be together on
this Mission and there's no turning back
this is not the end but the start of a
new adventure Maxim must choose whether
he wants to return home or get control
over this strange planet to lead a new
life